Mà ra, a người vừa, chào sổ hồng cho khu dân West Guys social tháng bản ra hoa cần hộ.
Mới đây, tập đoàn bất đổ sản a ra, má trường hoàn a người vừa,
chính thức bản ra sổ hồng cho khu dân West Guys đánh dấu cuộc mốt quan trọng của dự án social tháng
hoàn thành bản ra hoa cần hộ. Tại là tại chúng tôi hành chính mình chẳng,
khu hức hợp West Guys của bốn tỏ tháp cao hai mình tổng vừa phí mô khoảng 2 ngày cân.
Khiến đông là khu dân đã sọn về ăn cư và hình thành giịp sống như đây.
Tự tế, a ra đã có kinh nghiệm khoảng hơn một tập khi cho đổi phân khúc nhà ở vừa tụi tiền tại thành phố chiming và hút bục phí nằm.
Bằng việc tập trung mở giống quyết dất, a ra thì cực biến kiếm cơ hội thực hiện M&I.
Ý tiền các dự án đều chức thận chủ trung đồ tư, phù hợp phát triển dự án vừa tụi tiền, tư răng chế khai nhé.
Qua niềm của a ra là không vừa quyết đất hai mô dự án bằng mò ra.
Thế đó, công ty sẽ còn những phân thích kí tràng về khu đất để làm sao khi đưa ra thì chương ra tình sẵn phòng phù hợp với tuy tiền của mùa.
Đông thời, kinh định với mục tiêu phát triển dự án trên đến càng pháp liy miếng bạc, sẵn phẩm chất lượng, dịch vụ tận tâm.
Các dự án chế hai gần đây như Westside, Bình chẳng, đồ stand-up, bình dương, tụi vừa mua nhớ thiết kế, tự ý kiện đại.
Đảnh bảo tế độ bằng sau nhà, hoàn thành cấp dây chiến quyền xử dụng đất quyền xe hiểu nhà và tệ sản cho khu dân.